traffic jam is a common problem for big
cities not only in Brazil within the
world people get stuck in traffic them
all the time and they lose a lot of time
we have economic losses and pollution
tackling this problem is a challenge
devil travaglio liberado Pell associação
national transport publico key most
rocky new energy una vez en tous en la
vente wait 40 gastos safe vinci dos
millones de me ketut adios coma desde
cuando media which nós temos Kroshka
meet you there tres veces mice as a
support it den bruh nokia proposal know
where each image guy asked you on me
Africa every day you have more cars and
roads in the streets and it's really
hard to change the infrastructure to
support that so right now we are jointly
stood in this problem the main point you
are trying to answer here is how we can
predict the traffic condition in the
near future to predict the future
basically you have to know that the best
the traffic prediction project uses data
available by social networks Department
of Transportation and data that a user's
grade themselves while they move around
the city the idea is to combine all that
and to create a solution in real time
helping the users to get from point A to
point B in a more efficient way this
project uses Microsoft Azure as the
plataform to enable it as a service
Microsoft Azure helps us a lot in
building the traffic prediction model
because it is a lot of data for instance
the traffic flow from bing maps traffic
incidents informations available through
sensors on the roads social networks for
instance foursquare Instagram where
people can share their locations all
those kind of informations can be
combined to forecast the traffic jam for
the next 15 minutes 30 minutes 1 hour we
need to collect data from long periods
of time and process them given the
processing and storage capabilities of
azure this was fundamental for our
project the main series that I applied
the prediction models are New York Los
Angeles London and Chicago the model
presented great results more than eighty
percent of accuracy using only traffic
flow data and we still are working on
the characterization of other sources
such as traffic incidents and social
networks moyes applicati vu o mio es
policía de mais vous de ellos SE stint
ultra balakan sarah's estoy casado z4
missoni varias head so CIA's ultra
tambien status Canada I assess
informação es esto Nando's mais confiado
I pondered my spray silvano Cecilia do
controllable track the sedan
you